this is mr. Mack on the way to his
doctor's office mr. Mack has emphysema
he knows that this is a chronic lung
disease causing the shortness of breath
he has had for years the day is warm and
bright with Sun a day for enjoying life
for mr. Mack this sauntering gait is a
necessity he cannot move faster and even
at this pace must stop to catch his
breath lung trouble is not new to mr.
Mack he has had pulmonary tuberculosis
many bouts of pneumonia bronchitis and
numerous chest colds in his lifetime a
younger brother died of emphysema six
years ago he first noticed shortness of
breath 20 years ago if he hurried
upstairs or when he pushed his lawnmower
at the time he thought this natural for
a man fifty years of age as the years
passed he found that less and less
exertion called him to be short of
breath now a few stair steps are his
limit
he moves in a world that pushes by him
at a rapid pace 70 years old he feels
the weight of the past 20 years unable
to work in his garden or to pursue
simple normal activities comfortably he
finds his disease of physical as well as
a financial burden as a result mr. Mack
suffers periods of depression feeling
useless and frustrated
what is emphysema how did mr. Mack get
the disease can he be helped
how many other people have been Fathima
mr. Mack has known his doctor for years
the doctor has helped his patient
through several attacks of respiratory
infection that almost caused his death
today mr. Mack is to have a physical
checkup taking off his coat and other
garments for a chest examination causes
the patient to be short of breath he
paces his activity to hide the
difficulty he moves slowly so as not to
overtax his breathing capacity although
deliberately slowing his movements mr.
Mack suffers from a lack of oxygen the
demand of his muscles for oxygen is
greater than the lungs can supply and
oxygen debt results and his body economy
cannot continually run into debt work
must stop the oxygen debt must be paid
even while he rests breathing is
difficult and the breath short during
this period even conversation must be
interrupted for breathing the chest cage
is rigid moving very little the back is
bowed and the chest appears to be
enlarged from front to back the patient
leans forward in his chair to make
breathing easier his shoulders are held
I and his elbows are on his thighs
he uses his neck muscles to help get air
in pursed lips help the patient to expel
used air from his lungs more easily
paroxysms of Kaufer frequent and produce
sputum as much as a cupful a day
the whole face assumes a deep in color
but particularly the lips are dark the
arterial blood is not getting enough
oxygen
a normal chest sounds like rustling
leaves but the doctor hears little air
moving in mr. max lungs for distribution
of the inspired air is a major problem
in this disease on deep exploration of
wheeze maybe audible or sputum may
gurgle indicating the airway obstruction
present and probable bronchial infection
the chest x-ray shows many of these
abnormalities the lungs are over
distended too large for the chest the
bony cage is large and diaphragms are
low as though the lungs were pushing
everything out of the way the heart is
small as if it were compressed by the
large lungs the match test as a simple
means of finding this disease the object
is to boil out a lighted book match held
six inches from the mouth which must be
wide open this is easy for a normal
person but mr. Mack cannot get air to
flow out of these lungs rapidly enough
to extinguish the flame so serious is
the obstruction of the Airways mr. max
physician may use other tests to measure
the airway obstruction this instrument
is a spirometer which will measure the
rate at which the air flows out of the
lungs the technician instructs mr. Mack
to breathe in as deeply as possible and
then blow the air out as rapidly as he
can
the pen writing on rule paper follows
the flow rate during expiration the slow
delivery of the air may be seen from
such tracings here it takes mr. Mac 8
seconds or more to expel the air from
his lungs a normal individual in
comparison will do the same thing in 3
seconds or less in the normal lung fresh
air is distributed through the bronchial
Airways to minut air sacs in the latter
the exchange of oxygen and carbon
dioxide takes place to breathe in the
muscles concerned with inspiration
expand the chest cage and lower the
diaphragm much like the action of a
piston and a cylinder the pressure and
the pleural sac surrounding each lung is
reduced and the lung expands fresh air
is evenly distributed to the air sacs in
expiration the muscles relaxed in a
normal person allowing a small rise in
pressure in the pleural sac the lung
because of its elasticity returns to the
resting volume somewhat like the recoil
of a stretched rubber band pressure and
the pleural sac throughout inspiration
and expiration remains below atmospheric
levels in emphysema the resting lung
volume is larger than normal the lung
has lost much of its elasticity and its
ability to recoil in inspiration the
chest volume increases but the pressure
drop in the pleural sac is less mark
than in a normal chest the air sacs fill
unevenly and some have inadequate
amounts of fresh air for gas exchange
with loss of elasticity the lung will
not empty well to exhale the patient
must push the chest wall down on the
lung as a result the pressure becomes
positive
in the plural sack this
positive-pressure will collapse the
airways as well as the air sacs airway
obstruction results so this is emphysema
a disease of obstruction to air flow so
that respiration is work mr. Max disease
is in an advanced stage the lungs are
damaged too severely to be restored and
complete relief of symptoms is
impossible since it is known to
aggravate this condition mr. Mack should
give up smoking aerosols to clean the
airways and dilate bronchi and
antibiotics to combat infection afford
temporary relief years ago the disease
process might have been halted and this
stage avoided if treatment had started
when cough and sputum were the only
symptoms and an abnormal expiratory flow
rate the only sign the crippling disease
you see here might have been prevented
at present relief is always incomplete
when symptoms are very severe mechanical
aids to breathing are added to the
therapy these ventilate the lungs more
adequately and administer aerosols
effectively
although the cause of emphysema is
unknown much research is being done to
solve the puzzle of this disability the
structural damage to the lung is being
studied how severe is it what part of
the lung is affected even the proper
preparation of the lung for such a
structural study without introducing
errors is a problem
bacterial as well as viral agents are
being considered as causes of lung
damage emphysema is common in patients
with tuberculosis other types of
infections are also suspected of being
associated with the condition public
health and environmental research
studies indict smoking air pollution and
occupational exposure as contributing to
the progress of the disease whether
these agents alone will result in
emphysema or whether other factors must
be added is not known several diseases
may end in this crippling condition
pulmonary function in this disease is
deranged in many ways abnormal
distribution of air and blood in the
lung the work of breathing and the
abnormalities of the pulmonary membrane
between air and blood are under study
epidemiological sociological and
psychosomatic studies are increasing and
answers to some of our questions will be
forthcoming emphysema is not only an
individual but a community problem this
graph shows the mortality statistics in
California for three diseases commonly
mixed in their reporting chronic
bronchitis asthma and emphysema at least
some of the deaths from asthma and
bronchitis may as well be classified as
emphysema also shown as the death rate
for tuberculosis in California it is
evident that emphysema deaths are
increasing in contrast to death
from tuberculosis some patients who in
the past would have died of their
tuberculosis are now living long enough
to have emphysema national foundations
for the diseases shown here provide an
estimate for the number in the United
States today suffering from each malady
muscular dystrophy active tuberculosis
cancer of all types heart disease
including both heart and blood vessels
are a few for which figures are
available the incidence of emphysema
varies from eight to thirty percent of
the population depending upon the sample
a minimal figure of ten percent of the
adults in the United States would give
approximately twelve million people in
some stage of this disease the total
problem of emphysema is as large or
larger than many other diseases and is
increasing in magnitude emphysema as a
community problem has received little
recognition in this respect it is like
tuberculosis when Mr Mac had it 45 years
ago a chronic disease without known cure
and little public interest in it but
tuberculosis is being controlled through
the cooperation of science and an
enlightened public the same tools may be
used to control emphysema there need not
be mr. max in our future education of
the public regarding the contributing
causes emphasis on early case finding
rehabilitation of the disabled treatment
of the seriously ill and an intensive
investigative effort will succeed
emphysema too can be conquered